RAE:--um, strongly urging
this wonderful book on all of you.
"The White Tiger." How many of you have read this thing?
É One. Well, did you like it?
STUDENT: I loved it.
RAE: Yeah. It's better than Dickens at
looking through a system from the bottom up and making it entirely real.
So I strongly urge
that on you. And once you pick it up, you'll read ite
in one long session.
You need a little leisure for that, but
not a lot. The most-- the simplest thing to say about globalization and the poor
is that it has--
if you think about poverty in absolute terms,
it has alleviated a lot of poverty.
If you think about it in relative terms
it has made
a lot of people who
would not have thought about themselves as poor in
1840 or 1880 or 1920
think of themselves as poor now because of what's going on around them:
the volcanic eruption of wealth
around the globe.
I should also note there
that there's a coercive element
to economic growth.
Miroslav
referred to it very briefly.
But even when
there's no kind of obvious tyranny to the thing,
the marginalization of once--
once-remunerative and valid
ways of making a living--
what happens to the ten-hectare farm
once the scale economies
of global commodity production set in,
is that it's marginalized. It is forced out.
And skills that were once valuable become
less valuable. So there's all that going on.
But let's do-- this is, once again, Hans Roehsling's [sic] wonderful data animation.
And I hope I can...
I'm having real trouble with this. This mouse is
way too active for me.
Here we goÉ We're in 1840 here.
The vertical dimension is life expectancy; the horizontal dimension is income per capita.
And the scale on
both is linear. So we're not-- lodge scaling
makes it pretty tough to interpret
change
so now we're gonna play the movie for
about 170 years.
Each dot is a country. They're color-coded by the map up here.
The diameter of the dot represents population.
And watch what's happening.
Let's see if we can stop there for a second.
Ok. So far, what's happened, mostly?
Life expectancy has gone up
sharply
and at dramatically different rates, right?
It's mostly going up.
In Western and
North American settings.
It's going up very fast.
And in the background, not shown here, the birthrate is not going down.
So as life expectancy goes up,
death rates go down,
birth rates don't go down.
We're creating the population surge which
brings us nearly to 7 billion people today.
China is the big red balloon.
OK. So what--
what's the story? The story is:
life expectancy changing
and then wealth increasing for-- at
dramatic rates for about half the globe.
What's hidden in this
is that--
take India, the the large blue bubble--
is that in India, the vertical scale of inequality is going up fast, fast,
fast.
And "The White Tiger"
is that story.
I'm gonna stop there. And it's--
I think--
Is it-- I think it's Ambassador Hall's turn, am I right?